[Musique]
c'est qui très dynamique où d'énergie
toujours joyeuse qui aime évidemment
s'amuser un camp comme n'importe quel
enfant de son âge a fait en effet du
foot elle c'est une très bonne élève à
l'école
la première langue étrangère du ski j'ai
été ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est
un cancer qui est pas là curable ans
l'espérance de vie des enfants et de
neuf mois en moyenne à 2 ans le taux de
mortalité pratiquement 200 %
il n'existe pas de traitement efficace
cure en france 1 ni même à l'étranger
il n'existe pas de cure ans aujourd'hui
qui ajuste traitements expérimentaux a
fait d'autres recherches et notamment
aux états unis
il se pourrait qu'il ya un traitement
qu'il soit plus adapté qui s'appelle
donc longue de son un produit par la
société cosmetics a beaucoup de français
un long ce traitement
beaucoup de familles françaises le
donnent à leurs enfants aux etats-unis
et le système de santé il est payant et
pas comme en france et et vous avez des
frais d'hospitalisation et les frères
test qui peuvent atteindre tout de suite
atteindre tout de suite des sommes assez
extraordinaire